o caixão
[Música]
a
trinta por cento
esse é o número que representa o aumento
da taxa de suicídio dos jovens
brasileiros nos últimos 30 anos
Oi jovens de 13 a 24 anos você lembra o
que você tava fazendo na cidade Bom
Provavelmente você tinha acabado de
entrar na oitava série e tava aprendendo
frações no recreio com seus amigos você
já não gostava mais de brincar de boneca
ou de pique-esconde Mas provavelmente
ainda tinha aquele ânimo para jogar
futebol
E essa era a realidade de pessoas de 13
anos
porém em 2021 esses jovens sofrem com
adultos
e eu lembro como se fosse ontem eu
Catarina a Maria Clara e Alessandra que
é uma colega do nosso projeto sentadas
no escuro do auditório do nosso Colégio
a nossa frente uma fileira de
professores de química física biologia e
se era o primeiro dia do cientista
Aprendiz um programa de pré-iniciação
científica do colégio que basicamente
ajudava a gente é desenvolver projetos
de qualquer área do conhecimento e eu
lembro muito bem de uma professora
Falando sobre como a gente precisava
pensar num projeto que poderia mudar o
mundo Ou pelo menos impactar essas
pessoas e aí o menino do nosso lado e
levantou a mão e começou a falar sobre
como ele gostava de solo lunar e outro
lembro levantou falando sobre células de
camundongo e foi muito aleatório Mas foi
muito legal também porque eles estavam
muito animados mas aquilo me deu uma
certa aflição ouvindo porque tava tão
distante da nossa realidade tudo aquilo
e na nossa na nossa redor que tinha sua
amigos com problemas de saúde mental
como depressão ansiedade e transtornos
alimentares e tudo aquilo parecia muito
negligenciado pelos adultos então eu
lembro que falando com elas eu fiquei me
expressei né A minha angústia e eu porco
surpresa eu percebi que eu não tava
sozinha aí foi nesse momento de
vulnerabilidade da Catarina que a gente
entendeu que era esse tema que a gente
queria abordar a esse tema que fazia
sentido pra gente e foi aí que nasceu o
nosso projeto de pesquisa primeiro lugar
a gente começou a procurar uns dados e
infelizmente a realidade que a gente
encontrou era assustadora era um fato
que os adolescentes estavam ficando
doentes
é mas a gente não sabia muito bem que
que tava acontecendo para esse jovem
estarem Nesse contexto mas para
responder essa pergunta a gente
precisava entender primeiro o que que
era adolescência E para isso a gente
encontrou um psicanalista chamado Eric
Ericson ele entendia que é nessa fase
uma das fases mais importantes para que
uma adolescente se tornasse um adulto
feliz realizado bem-sucedido porque era
na adolescência que por meio com a
interação com você mesmo mas
principalmente da interação do meio do
ambiente que você vivia que você formava
a sua identidade identidade Essa é
composta pelas suas crenças pelos seus
valores e até mesmo os seus objetivos e
como a Maria Clara falou com o texto ele
extremamente importante então conheci
mente a gente começou a desenvolver por
meio de uma bibliografia que é de
psicanálise até e sociologia da escola
de Frankfurt a gente começou a
desenvolver um projeto e a gente pensou
em quatro critérios de identidade que
seria o corpo aparece compras
o e popularidade isso seria basicamente
quantos jovens que atingir esse ideal
então quando ele quer ter o corpo
perfeito ou as notas perfeitas um
exemplo o pessoal meu seria que quando
eu tava na escola eu lembro de ter muita
vergonha de levantar minha mão porque eu
achava que os meus professores os meus
colegas todo mundo ia me julgar eu tinha
medo de errar de mostrar os meus erros
só que uma coisa que eu percebi depois
né que esse momento escolar é o momento
mais importante para você demonstrar
suas dúvidas só que ela nossa sociedade
hoje em dia não preza essa essa
valorização da humanidade da nossa a
gente se mostra vulnerável eles não a
gente não pode fazer mais isso a gente
tem que se mostrar como pessoas mais
robóticas assim digamos e um outro
exemplo seria o corpo porque quando a
gente vê os jovens postando nas redes
sociais eles demoram uma horas porque
tem que fazer aquelas pequenas
modificações corporais depois de botar
aquele filtro como se toda adolescente
tivesse aquela pele de pêssego que a
gente vê toda hora nas redes sociais
henr a qualidade Eu também tenho um
exemplo muito pessoal meu entre os meus
amigos eu sempre evitava ao máximo de
partilhar qualquer incômodo meu porque
eu morria de medo de ser enxergada como
um chá tão Inconveniente Só se a gente
for parar para pensar isso não é nem um
pouco saudável evitar de criar qualquer
tipo de conflito ou atrito em nome de
manter a quantidade de amigos que você
tem ou talvez até mesmo um status de
amiga perfeita de pessoa perfeita agora
em relação à aparência compras a gente
via claramente nos nosso Colégio sempre
uma pessoa era praticamente idolatrada
por um tempo só porque ela tinha o
telefone novo outra vez um sapato de
marca mas o Curioso é que essa pessoa
era praticamente esquecida quando aquilo
que ele vestia já não tava mais na moda
e tudo isso que a gente falou compõem a
nossa a nossa sociedade atual que é a
aceleração da modernidade então
basicamente o culto à perfeição aquela
cultura da produtividade a invasão do
Ritmo Industrial E aí a vida pessoal
pelo trabalho e principalmente pelos
tudo todas as palavras que a Catarina
falou podem parecer um pouco abstratas
mas na verdade todas as características
estão presentes muito na nossa vida mais
do que a gente acha porque são elas que
compõem a hipermodernidade
hipermodernidade foi um conceito cunhado
por lipovetsky e habermas dois
sociólogos Ele é bem auto-explicativo é
hipermodernidade Ou seja todos os
valores presentes na época da
modernidade de uma forma muito mais
intensa de uma forma hiper só que é
curioso desse momento é que a gente não
percebe essa intensificação então a
gente acha que a gente tá no século 21
temos um milhões de uma milhão de
possibilidades a gente pode escolher se
e escolher o que a gente quiser mas na
verdade todas as nossas escolhas são
influenciadas pelo que mercado disse ou
seja todo o nosso valor como pessoa como
ser humano passa a ser simplesmente um
valor o e consequentemente a gente cobra
perfeição de nós mesmos da mesma maneira
que a gente cobra perfeição de uma
mercadoria por exemplo mas isso ainda
pode parecer levemente abstrato então
para ilustrar o queria que você se
imaginassem um polvo gigante esse povo
gigante é a hipermodernidade a cabeça
desse povo é o mercado e nessa cabeça
são conectados vários tentáculos
gigantes e muito fortes cada tentáculo
afeta cada aspecto da nossa vida mas
principalmente cada aspecto da nossa
identidade ou seja tem um tentáculo
afetando o corpo outro aparência e
compras o outro sugando a popularidade e
assim vai mas a característica principal
é que esses tentáculos são tão fortes e
disso focam tanto que acaba que sua
saúde mental fica afetada e quando a
gente percebe que esses valores são
completamente surreais e desumanos a
gente consegue ter um pouco mais de
consciência sobre o que tá acontecendo
só que isso e todo mundo isso impacta a
nossas vidas como um todo só que imagina
um jovem vivendo dentro desse contexto
mas eu não jovem vivendo dentro desse
momento hipermoderno você não acha que
suas crenças seus valores seus objetivos
a sua identidade não ficaria a frágil
frágil Talvez o suficiente para ele
desenvolver um problema de saúde mental
bem essa foi a grande Pergunta do nosso
trabalho e a gente pra gente conseguir
responder fizemos uma análise com mil
jovens em escola pública e particular da
cidade de São Paulo entre 13 e 18 anos e
a gente obteve resultados que mostrou
que existe sim uma correlação entre a
saúde mental EA formação de identidade
desse jovem nesse momento e tem moderno
um dos primeiros dados que a gente
encontrou encontrou foi muito
interessante a gente viu o que os
adolescentes de escola pública que
valorizavam muito a popularidade ou seja
tem o máximo de amigos possíveis tanto
na internet quanto na vida real acaba
vão ter dificuldade a reconhecer os seus
próprios limites ou seja eram aquelas
pessoas que passavam por cima de seus
valores das suas necessidades age
impulsivamente
assim tendo atos imprudentes só porque
eles buscavam acumular maior quantidade
de amigos possíveis era uma busca quase
incessante de aprovação do seu meio isso
não é nem um pouco saudável para saúde
mental deles agora imagina um jovem quer
buscar um corpo ideal então ele sempre
quer seguir esses padrões de beleza a
gente viu que muitas vezes ele pode
desenvolver uma percepção não apurada da
realidade dele então isso basicamente
significa que ele pode parar de se
Enxergar como ele realmente é esse foram
jovens da escola pública isso foi muito
preocupante porque com o padrão de
beleza sendo completamente voltado
artificialidades Hoje em dia a gente viu
que esses jovens ficam no ciclo de
frustração muito grande e é muito
perigoso porque eles podem desenvolver
por exemplo algumas alguns transtornos
de alimentares e aí a gente viu um
contraste disso na escola E na escola
particular a gente viu que esses jovens
que buscavam o corpo perfeito
conseguiram minimamente atingir porque
eles conseguiram ter o dinheiro os
recursos suficiente para fazer os
padrões de estética só que a gente
percebia que como a Maria Clara falou o
caráter ilusório da hipermodernidade de
achar que você tá bem ele achava que ele
tava bem consigo e com os outros mas a
gente conseguir entender que na
realidade esse jovem continuava doente e
continuava buscando esse ciclo vicioso
de atingir o ideal que nunca vai ser
real outro dado interessante é o aluno
de escola particular que buscavam onde o
teu consumo ideal ou seja eles buscavam
sempre ter os eletrônicos mais
atualizados as roupas as tendências de
roupa de marca esse que valorizavam
muito isso muitas vezes tinham muita
dificuldade de aceitar as exigências da
vida ou seja se seus pais ou por algum
motivo eles não pudessem consumir aquilo
que ele queriam eles acabam se sentindo
extremamente frustrado uma sensação tão
grande que ele sofreu é isso porque eles
eram um tipo de pessoa que projetavam
seu valor como indivíduo nas roupas que
eles vestiam no celular que eles tinham
por exemplo e agora fofinho a
competência de colar o exemplo de
competência escolar a gente viu que os
jovens de escola pública que nem eu
falei do corpo eles têm uma relação
similar porque eles ficavam nesse ciclo
de frustração não conseguiram atingir as
notas ideais não conseguiu entrar na
faculdade dos sonhos então eles ficavam
nesse ciclo e criaram uma falta de
autodeterminação e o contraste disse
novamente na escola particular foi que
esses jovens que conseguiram buscar
esses esses ideais perfeitos de notas
perfeitas e tentativas eles conseguiram
mas perdiam os limites de si mesmo então
isso que a gente prova novamente que
isso vira um ciclo viciante de
produtividade que não é saudável para
ninguém todos esses dados que a gente
apresentou deixaram a gente muito
assustada porque a gente viu como o
ambiente que a gente tá e as pessoas que
se relaciona influencia a maneira que é
a maneira que a gente desenvolve a
maneira que a gente interagir com os
outros e até e principalmente a maneira
que a gente interagir com nós mesmos
então com isso percebemos que paragens
Em uma sociedade mais saudável
mentalmente não seria suficiente uma
mudança individual mas sim uma mudança
coletiva na onde como a sociedade
normalizamos coisas sutis como a
pequenas modificações de fotos nas redes
sociais até coisas mais sérias como a
cirurgia de plásticas por exemplo que
são extremamente violentas a gente
também normaliza a ideia de consumo
então a gente consome constantemente e
incessantemente até o ponto da gente que
gerar produção de lixo e não percebeu
que a gente está fazendo a gente
naturaliza completamente seguir qualquer
dieta maluca e restritiva só porque uma
celebridade disse ou a gente até mesmo
romantizam estudo doentio exaustivo em
nome da frase estude enquanto Eles
dormem em busca de um mérito inexistente
em todas essas características que a
gente normaliza elas são reflexo de uma
sociedade doente e uma sociedade doente
que cria pessoas doentes mas
principalmente adolescentes doentes e
agora acabou vai ser isso a gente vai
viver nessa sociedade doente e por fim a
gente não vai conseguir escapar dessas
mazelas da hipermodernidade
bem a gente parou para pensar e a gente
percebeu que existe sim uma forma talvez
que a gente desconstruir tudo isso que
seria basicamente a criação de uma
identidade autêntica isso porque a
identidade que é formada na
hipermodernidade não é nem um pouco
autêntica pelo contrário ela é uma
identidade de papel ela é fina frágil
faço se rasgada amassada jogada fora por
isso que a gente precisa criar uma
identidade mais firme uma identidade
mais genuína uma identidade autêntica E
para isso a gente precisa se afastar dos
símbolos do mercadológicos presentes na
hipermodernidade e nos aproximamos mais
de 100 e parar de olhar para a vida de
uma maneira quantitativa e começar a
olhar de uma de uma maneira qualitativa
parar de falar de likes de reais de
notas de quilos começar a falar sobre
diálogo
sentimento interações e até mesmo dor e
talvez você já tenha passado da idade de
13 anos há muito tempo ou ainda tenho 13
anos mas o que é importante refletir e
perceber é que a gente precisa como
sociedade desconstruir todos esses males
que a hipermodernidade nos traz porque
não podemos deixar jovens com 13 anos
sofrerem como adultos obrigada
[Aplausos]